le potager du roi est au coeur d'une
controverse suite à l'article du figaro
du 4 octobre 2019 qui explique photos à
l'appui
la dégradation du jardin l'école
nationale supérieure de paysage rappelle
que la construction du potager a
commencé en 1678 et que de nombreuses
restaurations ont été faites
malgré le manque de mécénat
effectivement les les photos montrent
des murs qui sont dans un état dégradé
puisque nous avons fait des diagnostics
assez approfondies et on sait
aujourd'hui qu'il y a une part
importante des murs 15% des murs qui
nécessite une intervention urgente 30%
qui nécessitent des interventions
rapides mais effectivement nous sommes
en mesure aujourd'hui de déployer un
programme de travaux des parcelles vides
ou abîmées des murets qui s'effrite des
arbres en mauvais état pour cela 4 5
millions d'euros vont être utilisés pour
des travaux de rénovation
l'objectif du potager et de retirer les
arbres pour reconstruire les murs et du
jardin puis replantés les espèces des
travaux qui commenceront fin 2019 et qui
s'étendront sur 2020 quand on refait un
mur ça veut pas dire que tout d'un coup
il ya d afrique et dessus il ya du temps
un temps de conservation de préservation
nos sols et un temps de remise en vie de
nos sols il ya un temps de mise en place
sur le mur le temps que le mur lui même
on va dire arrête de bouger
donc il faut compter entre le moment où
un mur héros fait est que ce mur est
beau d'un point de vue de la production
il faut compter bien 8,9 peut-être même
dix ans les dégradations datant depuis
la fin du 19ème siècle qui s'accumulent
et qui nécessitent aujourd'hui de
nombreuses restaurations les jardiniers
du potager du roi prévoit donc le
renouvellement du patrimoine arboré dans
les années à venir